ach ja leute also so sieht das ding aus
habt ihr auch eben schon gesehen
[Musik]
ich glaube erst mal gegen seinen kumpel
zu tauschen
ich hasse diese dinge die kann man
texting bestellt niemals eine chance für
amazon was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei
einer video gut dass ich du musst schon
darauf achten dass nicht drauf bin gut
dass ich heute einen letzten kamerafrau
auf die das jetzt mal eben hier für mich
ab filmleute viele vergleiche
wahrscheinlich den letzten part von hoch
tauschen gesehen also wir sind gerade
bei einem wir sind gerade bei einem ps
vier von scheider ich habe eine
büroklammer angefangen das hier ist das
aktuelle produkt falls ihr die letzten
folgen nicht gesehen habt schaut euch
die erstmal an
auf jeden fall geht es heute auch direkt
weiter ich habe einen neuen termin
gemacht betreffen uns gleich um 615
irgendwo in köln wo ich noch nie war mit
dem frederik wenn du siehst du denn hier
wird dem ricardo genau wir treffen uns
mit ricardo er wohnt hier irgendwo in
köln
ich hoffe amerika gibt es auch aber
eigentlich schon also ich fange jetzt
gleich los bevor wir losfahren wollte
ich euch noch mal schnell aufzeigen was
ich dann wieder für angebote bekommen
habe es war wirklich jede menge dabei
von jo ich tausche meine schwester bis
über ich tausche meine freundin bis über
war irgendwie noch lesen ein gewisser
malen hat zum beispiel geschrieben ich
kenne sie jetzt mal hier netterweise
seinen namen sich dass seine freundin
stress macht tausche meine freundin ein
das hier fand ich auch gar nicht
schlecht mikael wollte mir nicht geben
dann habe ich aber noch nicht darauf
geantwortet schöne grüße an dieser
stelle ich habe selbst viele angebote
bezüglich samsung handys bekommen sei es
jetzt 1 3 bis 5 bis sogar es sieben mal
nachgeguckt was das so gebraucht noch
wert ist und ich war echt schockiert so
ein samsung es drei oder s5 christel bei
ebay kleiner seien schon für 30 40 50
euro hinterher geworfen
deswegen habe ich das erste mal so oft
gesagt ansonsten wollten viele leute
eine shisha eintauschen
keine ahnung ist eine shisha unbedingt
mehr wert als ein psp controller hier
wollte so wie hier waren die xbox von
gegen den 44 controller tauschen also
auf jeden fall ein krasses angebot das
problem ist immer vor allem bei jüngeren
leuten achte ich darauf dass ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt so was krasses mit dem
tauschen will nämlich übel aber ich
suche mir eigentlich gezielt der ältere
leute hier können wir natürlich trotzdem
tauschangebot machen aber ich habe
manchmal das bedenken die eltern finden
das sind uncool wenn das kind irgendwie
das alte handy abgeben oder sonstwas
deswegen so richter eher die älteren wir
fand ich das mal los und ja ich bin mal
gespannt
ich hoffe ihr auch dann heute wird
wieder was cool ist eingetauscht let's
go leute wir sind jetzt noch kurz hier
einkaufen weil ich fliege morgen das
erste mal in meinem leben nach amerika
und ich war noch kopfhörer für den flug
und jetzt schauen wir mal ob wir
passende finden passen wer ist
eigentlich auch gewesen hätte ich
kopfhörer jetzt getauscht dann hättest
du diese naja egal wie kaufen welche die
eigene und da ist ein cooler kohle auto
aktive ganz toll schöne grüße an dieser
stelle
leute wir sind jetzt hier gerade auf dem
weg zum ricardo der wohnt nämlich am
arsch der welt in köln
und ich habe gerade noch mal mit ricaner
geschrieben er bringt auch noch seine
ganze familie mit
die man gespannt wie viele leute jetzt
gleich da stehen wir so leute wir sind
jetzt hier bei irgendwo einer tankstelle
ich bin wie immer erster also real ist
und nicht da es war da und gucken
vielleicht erkennt dass hier irgend
jemand von euch also wir sind hier in
irgendwo am rande von köln
wir haben jetzt also
[Musik]
also leute ich will jetzt hier mit die
karte das ist ricardo der heute meint
spahn hat und seine familie oder so
freut mich dass hierher gefunden wurde
hier der spielkontrolle habe ich im auto
rad firma cruz
also controller gegen den kühlschrank
wie lange lassen
zwei wochen vorher habe ich selbst
geschenkt bekommen also werden jetzt
hier ein mini kühlschrank von der marke
iveco sage ich auch nicht aber an die
den haben wollen schreibt über instagram
heute noch nicht mal sagen oder so
irgendwie und du gar kein verschmerzt
haben war ja sagt jason und jason
unterstrich punkt 19.10 war sogar muss
man auch sagen wir werden schon glaubt
da ist eh schon drin alles klar jungs
kann hier sonst irgendwo noch ein foto
machen als dieser mann ja ich würde mal
kurz das auto
wie seid ihr freilich zu bekommen oder
wie
damaskus hatte
bei der meisterfeier empfehlen so gitta
damit das feld was oder
da gibt es ja keine für keine ahnung
aber damit also ich kann halt getränke
reinstellen 50 oder super leute ich
zeige euch jetzt gleich mal was dieser
kühlschrank werte ist eine da war ich
wirklich überrascht weil es gibt
bestimmt ist welche die dann gehört ich
nur als gemacht jetzt vier controller
gegen so einen kleinen kühlschrank
wartet ab heute ich habe keinen plan wie
ich gerade aus ja ich habe gerade noch
geduscht damit die morgencrew nicht
machen muss bei für mich geht es ja nach
amerika an die interessenten unter euch
für den kühlschrank ich wollte euch nur
mal kurz zeigen wie teuer das ist was
den wert hat und zwar handelt es sich um
eine kühlbox oder einen mini kühlschrank
und zwar jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken
er ist es keine kühlblock ist ein mini
kühlschrank genau und zwar haben wir
hier dieses exemplar das wird hier
glaube ich immer oh 453 angeboten auf
ebay gibt es das für 100 euro also 99 95
natürlich ist dieser preis für ein
komplett neues exemplar das ding da ist
glaube ich zwei wochen alt also hat seit
zwei wochen erst kaum benutzt von daher
hat es eigentlich auch einen neuwertigen
zustand ich würde mal sagen wir können
uns auf 65 bis 70 euro einigen das heißt
wenn ihr sagt alex ich will den haben
das tauscht dagegen checkt man instagram
abschicken foto von dem was hier gerne
tauschen würde ich heiße dort einfach
alex wie und in den zehn tagen wo ich
jetzt nicht da bin habe ich den küchen
dahinter in der ecke platziert ich würde
sagen wir schauen uns das mal zusammen
an
[Musik]
ja leute also so sieht das ding aus habt
ja auch eben schon gesehen man muss ganz
ehrlich sagen viel geht nicht rein ein
bisschen geräusche macht das ding auch
was ich euch allerdings auf jeden fall
noch zeigen wollte man kann hier hinten
aushöhlen einmal gold und einmal hott
das heißt irgendwie kann man auch sachen
wärme da drin und nicht nur kühlen sowie
diesen schönen da kein ice t von der
marke ich kann sich lösen also leute so
viel zu dem kühlschrank ist ein feines
gerät kann man einfach nur so sagen da
hinten habe ich schon mein koffer
gepackt ihr seht dieses video morgen
wenn ich im flieger sitze und ich
wünsche euch einen schönen tag gibt noch
nach oben treibt mir auf jeden fall auf
instagram was ihr gegen den kühlschrank
tausch würde daher sich alex wie und wir
sehen uns aber nicht vergessen